Wow.
I think the talk is over.
That's the entire thing.
Yeah, hey!
I'm a
little hoarse.js right now.
Because I Selined in last night.
So yeah.
AGdubz
on Twitter.
You might know me from some of the pool talks.
I don't work
anywhere right now, so I'm going to introduce
myself as somebody who makes
mistakes.
These things happen all the time.
And this talk, depending on how
you think about it, could be about making
mistakes, but I'm not going to tread
on this too much further.
Some mistakes were made.
We understand.
But yeah.
Let's talk about cows in space, right?
Because what is my talk even
about?
I don't even know.
Cows in space.
Maybe that's not what we're here for.
We're here to talk about art.
Right?
This is some great art that I found on
the internet.
Yeah, I know.
Bummer.
Got to talk about JavaScript.
Yeah.
We're
going to talk actually a little bit about
ES6/2015, and I'm not going to say
that whole thing every time, because I think
it's garbage.
I'm just going to
say ES6, and if you think I'm wrong, I don't
really care.
So...
Anyways...
Let's talk about ES6.
But it's Ashley, so I'm going to have
to talk about something else.
And the first thing that I really want to
talk
to you about is abstraction.
Right?
And this wouldn't be a good computer talk
if I wasn't going to talk some Dijkstra for
you.
So the effective exploitation
of his powers of abstraction...
Bummer on the pronoun, I know...
Must be
regarded as one of the most vital activities
of a competent programmer.
So
when we're thinking about programming, when
we're really doing programming,
the behavior that we're doing is abstracting.
And so...
Okay.
Abstract is a
pretty abstract concept.
So let's talk about the abstraction principle.
And
another really big tome, called types and
programming languages, Benjamin C
Pierce defines it as...
Each significant piece of functionality in
a program
should be implemented in just one place in
the source code, where functions
are carried out by a distinct piece of code,
it is generally beneficial to
combine them into one by abstracting out the
varying parts.
This is something
we all do in our daily lives, potentially
one of the things we find most
satisfying when we program and can refactor
something into this one elegant
function.
And that's really, really excellent.
But I want us to understand abstraction on
a theoretical level.
So in order to
do the theoretical level part of abstraction,
I went to Wikipedia and got
this.
So it's pretty good.
Details from a common pattern -- the programs
can
work close to the level of human thought.
Leaving out details which matter in
practice but are immaterial to the problem
being solved.
And this is something
I want to flag for us.
The idea of something being immaterial to
the problem
being solved.
We know as programmers that one of the big
things we also do is
define the problem we're solving.
And so this is something that's kind of
tying that in, and I want us just to kind
of flag that.
So I'm going to take us on another little
adventure before I get to that whole
ES6 thing.
So I had the pleasure of working at the New
York City Web
Development Fellowship in its flagship year,
a boot camp program for people
who are unemployed or make very little money
to take them from six months of
no programming experience to being a junior
developer.
There are problems with
some of these programs, but this one was awesome
and they were all there and
there are students of mine in this audience
and I'm super proud I'm here.
One of the reasons I love teaching -- some
people are like -- if you can, do.
If you can't, teach.
I think that's real garbage.
So when I say I teach
beginners, beginners teach me, and a lot of
the lessons that are learned that
I want to share with you in this talk are
from interfacing with beginners on a
regular basis.
All right.
So something that I learned when I was teaching
is,
like, for beginners, iteration is really hard.
Right before I started, I was
at this meetup, and the dean of the school
was giving a talk and he was
like...
Hey, look at Ruby.
Ruby is so awesome.
Even your mom could understand
that Ruby array.
Sidebar...
Don't say that stuff.
Moms are smart and cool.
Don't be rude.
(applause)
Anyways...
So yeah, he was like...
Yeah, JavaScript, people don't
understand JavaScript.
He didn't understand JavaScript.
So that was the
problem.
But he has this point that's actually kind
of core and really cool.
So you might recognize these excellent hand
gesture people -- Abelson and
Sussman.
They wrote a book we'll talk about later.
But what they say in that
book is programs must be written for people
to read, and only incidentally for
machines to execute.
And this is a really big point.
People write programs.
People read programs.
The computers do stuff over
there.
All right?
We're really here to program for people.
And that's
something that we need to remember.
But there's a little bit of a trick here,
because what does it mean to write programs
for people to read?
People really
struggle with instructions sometimes.
This is a picture of my door.
In my cool
ranch.
Anyways, yeah.
So this is a struggle, sometimes.
What does it mean?
We
don't really know what level of abstraction
is good for people to read.
All right, so we go back into iteration is
hard.
And this is, like, a really
neat lesson.
So this array.each...
Like, I had this sinking feeling about it.
Saying -- yeah, people can read it.
Ruby is great.
Interestingly enough,
written in English by a Japanese person.
Anyways...
So yeah, I was like --
okay.
This is not working.
Everyone is having a lot of trouble with iteration.
This is supposed to be easy.
What's going on?
So I'm sitting at my desk one
day and my code teacher, Blake, is teaching
iteration in Ruby to the group for
the first time and I'm listening in and it's
not going well.
It's just not
working.
And it's not because Blake's a bad teacher.
Blake is awesome.
But I
hear this and I'm like...
I really should jump in.
What am I going to?
And I did something kind of bold.
Which...
If anyone knows me, isn't out of
character.
I was like -- I'm going to hijack this class.
And so I walk into
the class and I'm like -- hey, guys.
I have an idea.
And I'm not sure it will
work.
But I have an inkling that it might.
And what I would like to do is I
would like you to throw away all the Ruby
you just learned, and I just want to
teach you iteration in a language that you
don't know.
And I think it's going
to work.
You'll understand.
And people are like -- that does not sound
like a
good idea.
I'm like -- no, no Ruby here.
However...
JavaScript was awesome for teaching
iteration.
Because it expressed the underlying concepts.
If we look at it
here, I know all of us maybe don't like writing
all this syntax out.
I'll get
to that later.
But...
When we understand iteration, it's state...
Condition...
Increment.
I see it right there.
But in that Ruby...
It's not.
And so it was
really, really cool that I was able to be
like...
Hey, this is the stuff you
need to understand conceptually, that's exposed
by the language.
And you can
use this language to teach it.
And we didn't teach any more JavaScript for
another three months.
But we went back to Ruby and it was fine.
We used
JavaScript as a teaching tool.
So that's a really interesting thing to think
about.
And so I think about a quote from my secret
boyfriend here, this really
excellent physics professor, Richard Feynman.
Shh.
Don't tell my boyfriend.
He
says this, and this is kind of a mouthful,
but I think it's very interesting.
He says -- the real problem in speech is not
precise language.
The problem is
clear language.
It is actually really quite impossible to
say anything with
absolute precision, unless that thing is so
abstracted from the real world as
not to represent any real thing.
And so this I think really pulls out the
conflict we have of when we're programming...
Are we programming real things?
Or are these ideas that we have something
else?
And should we be trying to
turn programming into, like, real world language,
or should we, like, go the
other direction and decide...
Maybe that's not the right way to do it.
All
right?
And so we still have this problem of origin,
though.
So you may or may not
have recognized my cows in space painting,
which is a bull painting by Pablo
Picasso.
It's a beautiful rendition of what abstraction
is, and the fact that
it's not just one thing.
It's many different layers.
And here he says -- and
this brings us to some trouble.
There is no abstract art.
You must always
start with something.
After that, you can remove all traces of reality.
And
that's really what he does in that painting.
But we have a question here.
When
we're thinking about designing programming
languages, in particular as tools
for education, where do we start?
This start problem is a really big deal, right?
So I love this picture.
I
assume that people have seen this before.
But it's a very classic one.
It's
the only curse word in the talk, unless I've
slept.
So anyways, it says -- how
to draw an owl.
Draw some circles.
Draw the rest of the owl.
In a certain
sense, there's abstractions we have in our
programming languages that do this.
They do it to us.
And they do it to beginners, and I think we
can all agree
that it's pretty hard to draw an owl with
these instructions.
These are really
both problems.
All right?
We're just between a rock and a hard place
here.
We know abstraction makes
things efficient, but we also know that explicit
code makes it easier to
reason about, which makes it more maintainable,
which in the end maybe makes
it more efficient.
So where do we start?
What are we going to do?
All right?
And so now I will take you on a fantastic
journey, a personal voyage, you
might say, with Carl Sagan, where we say each
of it begins here, inside of our
head.
So the cows in space.
Right?
We're back to this.
All right.
So humans are beautiful pattern matchers.
We're actually just one
of the -- that's one of the best evolutionary
aspects of human beings.
Reading
books is terrible for us.
There's no patterns on the page and short-term
memory is terrible.
But we love making and finding patterns.
So we can look at
something like this.
The sky.
And somehow we see this.
You see it, right?
I
totally see it.
No?
Anyways, someone saw it, and then got a lot
of people to
agree.
And we form something like this.
When we find patterns and we give them names,
we build abstractions.
And
that's really cool.
But...
We need to be careful about the abstractions
that
we make.
Because these abstractions turn into ideologies.
And those ideologies
are where we form our culture and our community.
And so you might end up with
something like this.
This is a real horoscope, by the way, and
maybe astrology
is real, because I did rekindle my sense of
inspiration on Tuesday by dragging
my travel companions to the karaoke joint.
So who knows?
So it's all out
there.
We have no idea.
But what we do need to understand is that
Carl Sagan
is really not into astrology.
He calls this fuzzy thinking.
We saw patterns,
but the abstractions we made with the patterns
were wrong because they were
built on the wrong underlying mechanisms.
Our personalities are not formed by
the orientation of the stars.
Or at least, that's not something I'm familiar
with yet.
But we ended up with this.
And people do a lot of dumb things.
And spend a lot
of money based on this.
This is very real for people.
Bad abstractions are
real problems.
All right?
So let's talk about JavaScript.
All right.
JavaScript.
JavaScript has been a delightful beginner
programming language,
because it's lacked a lot of abstractions
that other programming languages
have.
We have libraries that kind of do that for
us.
But JavaScript itself --
we haven't really done it.
And that's about to change a little bit.
All right.
So JavaScript was invented on September 28th,
1980.
That is not really true.
This slide exists because that's when Cosmos
came out and I wanted to be on
theme.
That's the one reference I've got.
So in this, he says this: if you
wish to make an apple pie from scratch, you
must first invent the universe.
And I was like...
Yeah, totally.
Also, ES6.
Oh, no, that was me.
Not him.
That
would be cool if that was true.
So let's talk about ES6 right now.
All right.
From this spec, we see -- syntax is relaxed,
to enable it to serve
as an easy to use scripting language.
Relaxation is awesome.
I have been
relaxing pretty hard this week, even though
I've been pretty nervous about my
talk.
But relaxing isn't always the right message.
Sometimes you get something
like that.
So when we see that, we have to think...
What is the problem to be
solved here?
Is the goal of JavaScript to be easy to use?
Have we asked
ourselves that?
What is JavaScript trying to solve?
What's the problem?
What
will be JavaScript's legacy?
That's a big question, right?
When we go back in time, people look back
and
here like...
There was once this language called JavaScript,
and they'll say
this about it.
What will that be?
I don't know.
But it probably has something
to do with this.
This is an excellent tweet by Laurie Vos a
little while ago.
Says: fundamentally it's hard to think of
a compelling reason a brand-new web
dev would learn two languages if they could
just learn JavaScript.
If I can
pick any language that will work on the client
and the server, it might not be
JavaScript, but we don't get to pick.
All right?
So now let's talk about ES6 classes.
You might remember our little
robot friend here.
And he's warning us about aliens.
All right.
So sugar makes
me sick.
Actually, I have diabetes.
So sugar actually makes me sick.
But
syntactic sugar makes me queasy as well.
And part of the reason syntactic
sugar makes me queasy is that there's often
the chance that it's obfuscating
something conceptually below it.
And so when I see this, I'm like...
Oh, no.
What's going on here?
All right?
So let's go back to the script.
Right?
Even
though scripts include syntax for class definitions,
the objects are not
fundamentally class-based.
It's like...
Oh, that's interesting.
Why did we do that?
So you might not need class syntax.
Anyways...
This guy...
Oh, he's adorable.
I love this guy.
He has this amazing quote.
He says:
remember that all models are wrong.
The practical question is: how wrong do
they have to be to not be useful?
All right?
So...
All right.
How bad are we
doing here, with this class syntax thing?
Let's keep reading some more spec.
Love reading spec.
In a class-based, object oriented language
in general,
state is carried by instances, methods...
State is carried by instances,
methods are carried by classes, and (inaudible)
behavior.
In (inaudible)
structure, behavior, and state are all inherited.
Okay.
That's, like, a lot,
and if you have not been reasoning about this,
that might be a bit.
So what I
want to do is there's this guy named Reganwald
you might know from the
internet.
He says school stuff like this a lot.
He also wrote a blog post and
I'm not going to read this to you, but what
he talks about are -- prototypes
are not classes.
When you're teaching classes, you often say
-- a class is a
blueprint.
You basically have a blueprint, and then you
can build a house from
it.
Right?
Your house is your object.
The class is a blueprint.
Cool.
Prototypes, and
classes in JavaScript, they aren't blueprints.
They're model homes.
And while
you might leave your model home empty, someone
could also move in, and you
could live there, and so that's actually very,
very different.
So...
JavaScript classes are kind of like objects.
And they're not really classes at
all.
I might be saying -- go home, TC-39.
You're drunk!
No, no, that's not
what I'm saying at all.
This is not a hate talk.
I love TC-39.
Shout out to
all the work by everyone in Open Source who
does literally anything.
I just
want to add a perspective, and I don't want
to play down anything that people
have built.
Because those people are awesome.
All right.
So...
You could really shoot me down pretty fast
by being like...
What even is a class?
And this is a good question.
And, like, frankly, the
community does not have a good ontology around
what object orientation should
be.
You should look this up.
If I had another hour, I would go into it,
but I
do not.
Simula is where it started.
But what I'm trying to say about
JavaScript classes and the ES6 spec is that
we're trying to do maybe too many
things, and we're not bound.
We're just trying a little too hard.
You can go
to this place, right next to Madison Square
Garden.
It's real.
And this is the
perspective I'm trying to add -- there's this
great talk called thinking for
programmers.
He talks about writing, and he quotes this
cartoon, and the
cartoon says -- writing is nature's way of
letting you know how sloppy your
thinking is.
What I want to say is -- teaching is nature's
way of letting you know how
sloppy your understanding is.
Yeah!
All right.
So let's get into a couple of
things pretty quick.
This is going slow.
All right.
So those Abel and Sussman
people called this tome called structured
interpretation of computer programs.
And this was foundational, because what it
said was -- we are teaching
programming all wrong.
We're teaching syntax.
We shouldn't be teaching syntax.
We should be teaching concepts.
And that is a big change.
We're thinking about
JavaScript -- now we have a syntax that doesn't
follow up with a concept.
But
if we're teaching programming...
This is going to be a mess.
JavaScript will
be the introduction to programming concepts
for an entire generation of
developers, whether we like it or not.
It's happening.
We think about the
problems being solved -- when we're building
these abstractions, we need to
realize that one of the problems JavaScript
is solving is making entry into
web development significantly easier.
All right?
So this little guy, Peter Van Wry, he's really
cute, he wrote a follow-up to
the SACP called the CTM.
And he said -- we need to teach programming
as a
unified discipline.
And what this means is -- programming languages
are tools.
We need to understand that they are able to
address problem and solution
pairs.
And those are things that we call paradigms.
And some programming
languages are multi-paradigm.
Some aren't.
But this doesn't mean that there's
any bad or good language.
It's just a good tool for solving a problem.
And he
says this.
And so...
He says a good way to organize a programming
course is to
start with a simple language, and to extend
that language gradually.
And this is what he calls the kernel teaching
method.
In his book, he starts
people at nothing.
And then they build everything up.
They build scope.
It's
really cool.
And so...
In that sense, they're inventing their universe.
Their
universe is a set of abstractions that they
built because they felt the pain
of their absence.
So yeah, every beginner should write a kernel
language.
Yeah.
Just kidding.
That's a bad idea.
What we want to take from him is the
idea of the creative extension principle.
And what this says is -- again, we
build the abstractions we need.
The ones that we feel.
And in that sense, we
build the universe that's most appropriate
for the problem we're trying to
solve.
Ron Jeffries says I think this is not something
we haven't thought
about before -- don't pre-optimize.
Do it when you actually need them, not
just when you see you will need them.
So it's how the apple pie gets made.
Anyways...
So I have a summary here.
Just basically...
The slides are online.
And if you want to do this -- what I'm saying
is we need to take an
educational perspective when we think about
programming language design,
because programming languages are tools that
do that.
And this is not just for
beginners.
We're all really beginners, when we're trying
to reason about code.
And having our abstractions match the concepts
that our language uses is going
to make it easier to reason about.
I want to leave you with something more, though.
So I don't think we're
totally lost.
Classes are going to be in JavaScript and
that's cool.
But then
there's going to be more specs.
And I think we have a really cool opportunity.
So I ask: what do we even mean when we talk
about programming?
This guy is
Martin Heidegger.
I really like him.
He's one of my favorite philosophers.
And
he wrote a book, and in it, he says thus:
the most thought provoking thing in
our thought provoking time is that we are
still not thinking.
And this is
going to sound a little Kumbaya, but take
it seriously.
Are we programming
yet?
Like, I mean it.
All right?
There are people who are radically redefining
what it means to program.
And if we understand that programming is just
abstraction, do we need to be sitting at a
terminal, typing a lot of
punctuation?
All right?
There are people who are really changing that.
And I'm kind of pissed, because all of those
people are in grad school, and I
just don't have enough money for that.
And I think...
I think that we should
be doing it here.
Why are we not thinking like this?
All right?
This is Thomas
Kuhn.
He's a philosopher of science.
He wrote a book about why science doesn't
make progress.
It's really about the rearticulation of language.
That aside,
he says this.
And this is really important.
Scientists work from models,
acquired through education and through subsequent
exposure to literature.
Often without quite knowing or needing to
know what characteristics have given
those models the status of community paradigms.
Like, why are we...
We can do better.
We have an awesome opportunity to way
more radically think about how we extend JavaScript.
We don't need to join the
cool kids club.
Like, I think to a certain extent, some features
are kind of
like...
The Abercrombie and Fitch shirt of languages
in middle school.
We can
really, really change things.
All right?
Carl Sagan.
I'll end with this.
It is
far better to grasp the universe as it really
is, than to persist in delusion,
however satisfying and reassuring.
So I want us to think about our ontology.
Think about it a lot.
This is, like, actual work.
Even though it's not
necessarily code.
And the key to doing this is staying a beginner.
Always.
You
guys are awesome.
Thank you.
So...
I have one last thing.
In my last four minutes.
This is a shoutout
again, to all my beginner students -- when
I was a teacher, they made me a
website.
And the website is called Clap for Ashley.
And if you happened to
enjoy this talk or want to see something on
the screen, if you tweet at Clap
for Ashley now, it'll appear.
Thank you.
So...
The internet might not work
also.
No one is going to clap?
It happened!
You guys are great.